hi i'm cheryl chase and i play angelica
pickles
hi i'm eg daily and i'm the voice of
tommy pickles
hi i'm chris summer and i am the voice
of suzy
carmichael and i'm nancy cartwright i
play the voice of chuckie
fenster hi i'm cath cece
and i play bill and deleo dvl
hi i'm ashley reyes fillers and i play
dd pickles hi i'm timothy simons and i
play drew
hey i'm tommy dewey and i play stew
pickles i'm omar miller and i play
randy carmichael we're the cast of the
all new rugrats series and we're here
with
buzzfeed to take a quiz to find out
which character we
actually are
[Music]
how would your fellow babies describe
you brave messy
smelly bossy nervous kind i think that
unfortunately i'm gonna have to go with
smelly
like no one would describe me as brave
not really
not really messy i'm not really bossy
i'm a little nervous
like i don't know i do fine with
kindness i'm not like terrible but i'm
also not great so i'm gonna go with
smelly
i'd love to be kind but i'm i'm nervous
they would say
kind i want to say kind but you guys
already took it let me go out on a limb
here and go with brave
okay well i hope it's kind i would say
maybe bossy
i think i would say phrase i feel like
i'm kind of two things
one is nice kind lady the other is
panicked so i'm kind of a combo of
nervous and kind
if i had to pick one i'd pick kind and i
would pick kind for me too
i would pick kind too okay i just did
which rugrats grown-up would you trust
with a secret
stu drew that's who i play dede
charlotte chaz betty lucy
randy or lou i would probably
pick lucy susie's mother i agree you
think we picked susie's mama
yeah susie's mama i think i would
pick dede and i think i would pick dede
i think i would pick lucy i would it was
the toss-up between those two huh
i think they're the most dependable
right yeah one that you can count on
these
these like yes i would not go with drew
he might be the first
thought of who you might be like oh i'll
go with that uptight guy but i feel like
he would use the of secret to his own
advantage he would like spill it
somewhere else if it meant
that he would get something out of it
like he would use it as a uh like as a
bargaining chip
so i'm just gonna say not drew i feel
the same about my dude stu
i feel like he's just desperate for a
hit he's a
you know semi-failed inventor and if
spilling some beans meant
any kind of success he'd do it i'm gonna
go with chaz
played by the great tony hale i think
chaz is too nervous about the
consequences of betraying a secret
i would say lou
but then i think maybe he'd forget that
he wasn't supposed to say
and then he would i would trust dee dee
which is who i play
but i would do you think that there
would also be a possibility that lou
would just forget the secret altogether
you're right can i change i picked lou i
was thinking lou for that exact reason
that he he wouldn't remember my secret
so he couldn't tell it
but i'm gonna roll with betty choose the
famous baby
baby shark baby yoda baby groot
baby grinch baby spice and boss baby
i feel like everybody else on the list
is like a johnny come lately these are
all from like the last couple years so i
feel like we have to go
baby spice just because that's a classic
that has stood the test of time yeah
maybe spice is the only one with whom
i'm i'm
at all familiar we're going baby spice
on this one i'm not gonna choose
baby spice i want to choose
baby yoda because he's um wise
for his age we are huge star wars fans
as a matter of fact
i wear darth vader chewbacca and a
stormtrooper every day so it's
definitely it's baby yoda i would have
to say baby groot
i am picking baby groot also i'm picking
boss baby
and i'm going to go with baby yoda
what's your dream
reptar product backpack cereal
the green reptar bar socks a wagon
or stuffed animal i'm going with
backpack i've been thinking about
getting back in the backpack
game i went backpack three years ago or
so i've never looked back
i'm gonna go with the socks i tend to
dress in neutral tones
and i feel like a nice little pop of
color where the sock
can really dress up and otherwise drab
outfit neutral tones really
unfortunately like i'd love to get into
like a street wear kind of thing but
usually like the bright and bold colors
i'm just so large it just i feel like
it's kind of overtakes
a whole thing you know what i mean like
i just it's like so much fabric of like
a bright pink or a bright like you know
bright red this is exactly what rugrats
fans are looking for
i would like to pick a wagon i like the
idea of
being in a wagon on a trail being pulled
by horses since you took the wagon i'll
roll with the good old reptar bar if i
can get a reptar liquor license maybe i
can make some money
i'd have to say reptar cereal well it's
a wagon for me
it's a stuffed animal for me yeah me too
stuffed animal
it's going to be cereal for us you're a
team
i know i brought my own rugrat for
backup okay pick something from the 90s
pogs beanie babies walkman aol
nintendo 64 and slime without a doubt
slime
yeah i say slime slime for me too sony
walkman as a matter of fact i got one
for my oldest daughter two years ago
i'm gonna go with a walkman because i
want to take that music with me wherever
i go
i'll go aol that was the beginning of
online
communication this started what we're
doing right now which is going
so well it's going great i feel like
that's one note that we can have for the
internet is that there has been no
ill effects just been a 10 out of 10.
but i am actually going to go walkman
the very first uh cassette tape i ever
bought was a weird alagankovic's
even worse and i remember just the pride
that i had and like walking down the
street listening to
weirdo yankovic oh yeah i'm gonna go
within nintendo 64.
i was a serious gamer and 64-bit
graphics changed the world i remember
they playing madden and they had it
where if you played in the winter there
was actual smoke coming out of like the
linebackers mouths and stuff
too insane what's your biggest fear the
dark
not getting attention clowns heights
nothing everything it's not getting
attention because if i'm not getting
attention it
means i'm unemployed i'm gonna go ahead
and just answer for every actor that if
anybody doesn't say not getting
attention
then they're lying i'm just gonna call
that out for every actor everything a
close second i'm gonna say heights
i'm gonna rock with you with the heights
i'm not too crazy about heights
no heights for us okay yeah no hikes for
me either i'm gonna go with heights to
you guys
i'm gonna go with chucky and say clowns
i'm not gonna go with chucky i'm gonna
say nothing
all right bring it on baby
finally it's snack time what are you
eating
cookies milk worms toilet water grilled
cheese or fruit snacks
i don't eat cheese anymore but i would
have to say grilled cheese
yeah that's me too i picked grilled
cheese me too
that's three grilled cheese for me i
live on pomegranate seeds so i'm gonna
say fruit snack
go on fruit snacks i've stolen a lot of
fruit snacks from craft services over
the years
i'm gonna go with grilled cheese on this
one i'm going grilled cheese too
i'm gonna go grilled cheese too i have a
little bit of a restricted diet just
because of some
allergies so really there aren't any
options on there so buzzfeed
maybe open this up to people with
dietary restrictions due to allergies i
don't want to call buzzfeed out but you
know i am but i'm going to go grilled
cheese just because that's the closest
oh who are you guys
you're susie too you're little susie i'm
phil
i'm chucky how could that be he's just
afraid of
everything
i'm proud to say that i'm susie i'm
susie
she's so cool i'm susie you're supposed
to be over both susie
i'm tommy i'm phil i'm a little messy a
little scary and more than just a little
bit gross
thanks so much buzzfeed make sure to
watch the new rugrats on paramount plus
yay
you